So then let's get started with uh
I guess our second-to-last topic today,
which is going to be something called uh
cheap talk.
I think it's good to have some context
for this. So so far we've looked at
signaling games.
And
so let's recall
that when we looked at signaling games,
people with private information were
conveying information to some other
party through costly actions. So under
signaling
info is conveyed
through costly
or we might also say payoff-relevant
actions.
So one way to convey information about
how smart you are, how good of an
employee you are, is to go to college.
And the whole point of that model was
that going to college is costly and
differentially costly for different
kinds of people. Or when a firm was
conveying information
um about the quality of an item, they
were setting a price, and maybe a price
isn't directly costly, but it is
payoff-relevant because the price I set
affects how much money I get if you
actually uh accept
uh my offer.
But, you know, in the real world, we see
a lot of information conveyed not
through costly actions, but just through
speech, through communication. We send
messages to people, we use words, we
talk to people.
And the question is, when there's a
conflict of interest, can we also convey
information through costless actions? So
today, the difference is we're going to
look at uh
conveying information
through costless
and sometimes instead of calling these
actions, we might call them messages cuz
we usually think of speech or words or
messages as being costless.
Now, there are certainly some contexts
where this isn't going to work. If we
think of the job market signaling
example, the firm could could ask you
how good of an employer are you?
Well, everyone's going to say they're a
good employee, right? So there are some
contexts where we really need a costly
action in order to make it credible the
information that we're going to convey.
There are other situations where it's
clear that interests
then of course we can communicate freely
and that's not going to be difficult. So
the the the point
of the model today is going to show that
sometimes there will be a a misalignment
of interests, there'll be a conflict of
interests, yet nevertheless some kind of
communication can be credible in
contrast to the model of telling the the
employer that you're a good employee. So
that's going to be the the model we're
going to look at today.
So this model is based on a paper by
Crawford and Sobel
in 1982.
So we're getting
you know, closer to modern topics.
And we're going to think of this is a
game between a sender, we call them
sender and receiver.
But I want you to think these are
abstract labels. I want you to think of
the the sender as an advisor and the
receiver as a decision maker.
So and the presidential advisor might
collect information and and make a
recommendation to the president about
what tax policy should be or to the Fed
about what the interest rate should be
or how much we should spend on the
military. And the idea is that the
sender, the advisor, has more
information than the decision maker cuz
the decision maker is very busy. The CEO
can't know about everything. They talk
to a consultant or
uh an an a researcher who's going to be
very informed about this particular
issue. So how do we model this? Well,
the sender
is going to uh privately observe
what we're going to call maybe a state
or this could also be called their type
T in 01.
So we're going to think of this, you
know, in our economic example, how good
is the economy?
What's the ideal amount of spending we
should spend on the military? What's the
ideal tax rate? So this makes sense for
any decision where uh there's kind of
this one-dimensional choice uh that we
have to make.
We can think of this usually as the
state of the world, uh but we'll also
call it the sender's type because this
is private information that the sender
has.
And then the sender, after observing
their type T, is going to send a message
M, we'll just call it in some abstract
set big M
to the receiver.
And then the receiver is going to
observe
M, but not T.
Right? The whole point is if the
receiver, the decision maker, understood
the state of the world, knew what the
right decision was, they wouldn't need
help from the advisor anyway.
So they don't directly observe T, but
they do observe this message that's sent
by the sender.
And then after that, they choose an
action or decision
which we'll call Y, and that's going to
be a real number.
So maybe I'll say
uh I don't know if I've used this
notation before. This is just the set of
real numbers.
Um
Now, whenever we talk about something
being privately observed, we need to
specify the distribution from which this
comes. And we're going to assume that
the state, just to make things easier,
is uniform.
So just to be clear, the sender knows
what the state is, they know their type.
The uniform distribution is relevant to
the receiver. The receiver believes that
the state is uniformly distributed, but
they don't know what the actual value of
the state is.
We also say uniformly distributed.
And now let me specify payoffs. Of
course, this is a very stylized model,
but I think it captures um a lot of
policy disagreements that that we have.
So the sender
their payoff US depends on the decision
Y that the receiver takes
and also T, the state of the world.
And same for the receiver.
And
what we're going to imagine for the
receiver, to make things simple, is the
receiver just wants to match their
decision with the state of the world.
So we could think of
the state of the world might be
uh
the some measure of how close the
economy is to a recession
and Y might be uh how much we're
planning to cut interest rates.
Or T might be the severity or the risk
of some military conflict and Y might be
the the spending level that we spend on
that conflict. And the idea is these
things move together, the higher the
state, the higher the ideal decision for
the receiver. So we'll formally model
this
with the quadratic function that we've
uh loss function that we said before.
So this means what the receiver would
love to do is have the decision exactly
match the state. So we can think of the
state as basically measuring what would
be the ideal decision for the receiver
if they could observe the state.
And then the receiver experiences a loss
that's equal to the difference between
their decision and the state squared. So
how far off the decision is from the
state. Yes? So basically the decision is
just a reflection of what the receiver
believes that the state is.
Uh
it's true that their preferences over
the decision
depend on their beliefs about the state.
Um
>> what exactly matches the state, right?
So it should be
So is the decision like supposed to be a
state?
No, I wouldn't um I think what one maybe
one way of interpreting this is
Okay, if we want to think about a richer
model, probably the state is really
uh a very rich multi-dimensional object,
but we're going to denote the state that
the aspect of the state that matters is
what the ideal decision is in that
state.
So I think maybe the better
interpretation is when we write T, what
we really mean is what is the receiver's
ideal decision given the the state of
the world. So maybe the economy has many
dimensions, but think of T saying the
ideal interest rate for the Fed to set
is 3% and Y being the interest rate the
Fed actually sets.
Does that make sense? Yes. Yeah. Okay,
great.
So now what about the sender? Well, if
the sender and receiver had the same
preferences, this would be a really easy
problem. Of course, the advisor is going
to just reveal the state and allow the
receiver to make a good decision. But
often advisors and decision makers have
misaligned interests. And the way we're
going to capture that here is we're
going to say the sender's preferences
is like this
where beta, maybe I'll put it down here,
is greater than zero.
So here beta is called the bias.
This is the bias that the sender or the
advisor has relative to the decision
maker.
So notice that well, the receiver always
wants to match the decision with the
state,
the sender would like to match the
decision not with the state, but with
the state plus this bias beta.
So notice some characteristics of this
misalignment of interests.
Both the sender and the receiver agree
that when the state is higher,
a higher decision is warranted.
What they disagree about is the exact
value of the decision. So whatever the
state is, the sender always thinks the
decision should be a little bit higher
than the receiver thinks. And I think
this is consistent with um a lot of
policy disagreements. Let's take the
example of the Fed. There are some
people who are more hawkish and more
dovish on inflation.
So some people always tend to want lower
interest rates than someone else. But
everyone agrees that when the economy is
in worse shape, we should tend to um cut
interest rates and the economy is is is
doing well, maybe we should raise
interest rates. So um they all agree
about the directional effect of the
state on the ideal decision, they just
disagree slightly uh about what the
level is. And the sender always wants a
decision that's higher uh than what the
receiver wants exactly by this amount
beta.
So the larger beta is, the greater the
disagreement between the sender and the
receiver.
Okay, so here's our model. Any
any questions about the model so far?
Yes.
Is beta just like depends on who the
sender is? Like it's not like
distributed, it's just like being
correct with Good question. So you could
imagine a richer model where the
decision maker doesn't know the
political biases of the of the advisor,
and that's actually interesting
extension that people have looked at,
but for today we're going to assume beta
is commonly known. So I hire this
advisor, I know that my advisor
always, you know, tends to have this
policy preference, and this is known.
What I don't know is the true state of
the
Good question. Any other questions?
Okay. So it's a game. Let's first think
about what strategies are in this game.
So the sender
they observe the state of the world or
they observe their type T
and they choose what message to send to
the receiver. So a strategy for the
sender is a function M
from 01
to this abstract set of messages M.
Maybe we'll
go into here just to understand what
goes on.
So what this says is if I see that the
state is say 0.3, this is the message I
send, M of 0.3. If I see that the state
is 0.7, then I might send a different
message, M of 0.7.
Now the receiver strategy, well what do
they do?
They see the message, and based on the
message that they see, they choose a
decision to make.
So for the receiver, a strategy is a
function Y
from M
to
maybe we'll say R.
Just to understand what's going on.
I'll write it like this.
So the receiver says, if I get a message
M from my advisor, this is the decision
I'm going to take, Y of M.
And the solution concept we're going to
work with
is going to be PBE as before, perfect
Bayesian
equilibrium.
Now let's start by kind of analyzing
how things work for the receiver.
So with perfect Bayesian equilibrium,
whatever message the receiver sees,
they're going to update their belief and
then behave optimally given their
updated belief.
So let's just
remember
that whenever we work with perfect
Bayesian equilibrium, we have to
distinguish between the messages that
occur on path and the messages that
don't occur on path. So a message M is
on path if in a given strategy profile
there's some state of the world where
the sender actually sends that message.
And a message is off path if that
message is not supposed to be sent in
any state of the world.
So if the receiver sees an on path
message M
they apply Bayes' rule.
And then they using Bayes' rule, they
have an updated belief about the state
of the world T.
But because of the nature of our
preference relation, the the nature of
our utility function
the receiver always wants to take the
decision that's equal to their updated
expectation of the state.
So they apply Bayes' rule.
They can now compute
maybe I'll say E of T given M.
What does this mean? It says, I observe
M
I update my beliefs about the state of
the world and I'm now going to compute
what I think the expected value of the
state of the world is given my updated
beliefs.
And it's always going to be optimal for
them to to take this as their decision.
Compute that, and in fact, that's going
to be their decision.
They're going to update their beliefs
about the state, compute an expectation,
and set their decision equal to that.
Off path well
the beliefs over 01
are unconstrained.
Because we can't apply Bayes' rule.
So off path, the receiver can
believe anything about the the state
between 0 and 1.
So the key question is, what decisions
could the receiver take if they see an
off path message M? What are the range
of decisions that are consistent with
some belief?
Yeah. Just the real numbers.
So
we might think it's all the real
numbers, but is there any belief that's
consistent with taking decision Y equals
2?
We know T is lives in 01.
So the point is, and this is kind of a
subtle point,
the point is
I can form any belief I want about the
state, but we know the state lies
between 0 and 1. So the most pessimistic
belief I could have is the state's
definitely 0.
And the most optimistic, or here it's
not clear what's optimistic, but the
highest belief I could have is the state
is certainly 1.
And in those two cases I would take the
decision Y equals 0 and Y equals 1. So
I'm always going to take a decision
take some decision
Y that's always going to be between 0
and 1.
Because those are the decisions that are
consistent with some belief about the
state.
Any decision in here can be justified by
some belief about the state. I could
take decision 1/2 because I think the
state is certain to be 1/2, or maybe I
think it's uniform. Um those are all
going to be okay.
Uh
it's going to turn out, as we'll see,
that
the off path beliefs are not going to
play as big of a role in this model as
they did in the signaling model, um but
we'll see that a bit later. So so let's
start with, just to kind of build
intuition, a really simple
equilibrium.
And the simplest equilibrium would be a
no communication equilibrium.
Now when I say no communication, what I
mean is no information is actually
conveyed. Of course, they're actually
going to send a message because they
have to.
But you know, one thing the advisor
could do is they could be a broken
record. They could just always send the
same message. And if they always send
the same message no matter the state of
the world, then that message doesn't
convey any information about the state.
So let's look at this kind of boring
equilibrium. Well what is let's fix
some message I'll call M star in M.
This is going to be the message that the
sender always sends no matter the state
of the world.
So the sender strategy is M of T
equals M star
for all T
in 01.
So going to our economic example, if
they see the economy is great, they say
cut interest rates. If they see the
economy is bad, they say cut interest
rates, and therefore what they say
conveys no information
about the state.
Now let's try to compute what the
receiver is going to do in this case.
So
let's now look at the receiver.
And what happens if the receiver
sees the message M star?
What beliefs does the receiver form
about the state if they get this message
M star?
Yeah. Wouldn't they just going to be
left with the prior which is that T is
distributed over 01? Exactly. They'd
just be left with the prior because they
know whatever the state is, they're
going to get this message. This hasn't
told them anything. If you always say
the same thing, you haven't revealed
anything to me. So my beliefs are the
same as the prior. So if I see M star
uh maybe we could say retains
prior beliefs.
That is, I still think the state is
uniformly distributed over 01.
And the average state is therefore 1/2.
So the best decision for me is to take Y
equals 1/2. So it retains prior beliefs,
and they take so Y of M star
equals 1/2.
So this looks good for our equilibrium.
But we still have to worry, well
we have to say, what does the receiver
do if they see
a message M that's not equal to M star?
Right? They don't really know what to do
in this case because they were expecting
to always see the message M star. They
can't really apply Bayes' rule here
because they'd be dividing by zero. So
there's a lot of flexibility.
Um
you might say, oh let's just choose Y
arbitrarily.
But what could go wrong if we just
sort of chose Y arbitrarily here for the
receiver. Let's say we chose Y
equals
uh
you know
1/3 or something.
What could go wrong here? Yeah? Maybe
the sender will like there will be a
profitable deviation for the Exactly
right. So whenever we're choosing the
off path behavior by the receiver, we
have to keep in mind that we don't want
to choose behavior that will introduce a
profitable deviation for the sender. In
this equilibrium, the sender is only
supposed to send the message M star. So
we want to make sure that the sender
never wants to deviate to send any
message other than M star.
So how can we be sure? How could we
choose Y of M to be sure that the sender
never wants to deviate? Yeah?
You could make it so that the difference
between
like they get the same uh utility from
getting M star
Exactly right. And how could we make
sure they get the same utility? I
don't know exactly what the equation is,
but depending on beta, right?
Right. Well but I think you're on the
right track. I think there's even a
simpler answer. So you're exactly right.
We want to make sure that if they
deviate to this, the sender gets exactly
the same utility. But what could it be?
Yeah?
It could just be 1/2, right? So what
they could do is they could say, "Look,
if I see any other message, I'm going to
do exactly the same thing. I'm just
going to choose Y M equals 1/2. I'm
going to maintain my prior belief." So
let's understand the structure of this
no communication equilibrium. The
receiver says, "Whatever message you
send me, I'm going to do the same thing.
I'm going to completely ignore you."
And the sender says, "Well, if you're
going to ignore what I say, it doesn't
matter what I say, so I might as well
always send the message M star."
And this kind of sometimes goes over the
the name This is sometimes called
babbling.
So in this equilibrium, the receiver is
treating his advisor's words as just
babbles. I don't care what you say, it's
not going to change my belief. I'm just
going to, you know, ignore what you say
and do the same thing. And therefore the
advisor says, "Well, I might as well
always send this message M star."
Um so indeed, this satisfies
Let's just check what we would have to
check to make sure this is an
equilibrium. We'd have to check sender
optimality,
receiver optimality,
and belief consistency.
I've been a little imprecise. I haven't
really written what the beliefs are
here, but naturally,
the beliefs could be I just think the
state is uniformly distributed if I see
any other message. And then we can see
uh that each of these three conditions
is going to be is going to be satisfied.
This is not a very interesting
equilibrium, but it's just good to see
this always an equilibrium like this
where
uh our words just don't have any meaning
and no one listens.
Well, that's one extreme. Let's see if
we could do better. We might want to
have perfect communication.
So what about an equilibrium where
there's perfect communication?
So you might think, "Well, if the
advisor and the decision maker have a
pretty good relationship, what should
happen is the advisor should just say,
'This is what the state is.'"
So could there be an equilibrium
where the message M of T
just equals T? So the advisor says,
"This is the state. Make a decision."
Any thoughts? Could Could we make this
an equilibrium?
Yeah, hit me. I think it's not an
equilibrium because uh the receiver
would just act with Y equals T as a
result. And then the sender is losing
some amount because Y does not equal T
plus beta. Right. So let's work through
it. If we tried to This is not going to
work, but let's kind of go ahead. If we
tried to have an equilibrium where this
was the messaging strategy of the
sender, well, this looks great for the
receiver. What is the receiver Y of T
going to be? Let's be clear here.
The receiver's strategy is not a
function of the state, it's a function
of the message, right? But here the
message is the same as the state. So
that's why I'm writing T. Um
so Or actually, I maybe I'll still write
uh
torn about which notation to use. It
doesn't make a difference.
I'll write M.
Uh in this case, when they see a message
M, they're going to say, "Well, that
means the state T equals M."
So their best decision is just going to
be
M.
Right?
But now, let's put yourself in the shoes
of the sender.
And let's say you see that the state is
C is T.
If you were the sender, what message
would you send to your to the decision
maker?
Yeah? T plus beta. Uh exactly.
So
you know the state is T. Well, why don't
you just say, "Look, you're going to
tell the advisor
M equals T plus beta."
And I think we see this
all the time, right? If someone's more
of an interventionist and they know that
the president is less of an
interventionist and they want them to
intervene in the conflict, they don't
say, "I'm an interventionist." They say,
"Oh, this conflict is just really
serious. It's really important to
intervene. I'm not saying it cuz I'm an
interventionist, it's just the nature of
the conflict means we really have to
intervene." Or someone who always wants
to
um
cut interest rates isn't going to say,
"Oh, let's cut interest rates cuz I love
cutting interest rates." Um they're
going to say, uh "Inflation's not really
a problem. We're not really having any
inflation. I think this is what you
should do."
So the sender has an incentive to
misrepresent what the state is in order
to get their ideal decision because they
know if the receiver believes the state
is actually T plus beta, then the
receiver will take decision T plus beta,
and that'll give the sender exactly what
they want. So we see that indeed this
cannot be an equilibrium
because the sender has a profitable
deviation and then the receiver won't
trust the messages and everything breaks
down. So not an equilibrium.
But now we have a bit of a puzzle.
We definitely see communication in
practice between people who have
misaligned interests.
Um
we don't just see this no communication
equilibrium. So the question is, well,
if we can't get a perfect communication
equilibrium, maybe it's possible to have
an equilibrium where we have some
partial communication. We don't
perfectly reveal the state, but we
provide some valuable information about
the state. And that's going to be the
key idea of this of this paper.
So let's our goal
is to find well, maybe not perfectly
informative equilibria, but partially
informative equilibria.
Let's start with, you know, a really
simple case. I guess the simplest
possible message you could send about
some real-valued state is you could say
the state's either higher or low. You
could just say it's either above a
threshold or below a threshold. So let's
Let's see if we can
work with that.
So the state
is here between 0 and 1.
And let's say we choose some threshold.
We'll call this threshold T1.
And what's the sender going to do?
If they see the state is below T1,
they're going to send a message maybe
we'll call the message L.
They're going to say, "The state is low.
The state is below T1."
And if they see the state is above T1,
they're going to send a message H.
Saying the state is high.
And
we want to see if this could be an
equilibrium. You might worry because you
might think, "Well, wait a second, isn't
the sender going to want to lie
and pretend the state is high when
sometimes it's not in order to get their
higher preferred decision?" That's a
good intuition, but it turns out we can
get this to work, which I think is maybe
a bit surprising. So let's Let's go
through this.
So what is Y of L going to be and Y of H
going to be?
So T1 is a parameter that we're going to
solve for. Okay? So we're going to look
for an equilibrium that has this form
for some parameter T1. And this is what
we're going to figure out. Okay? So what
happens if the receiver sees the the
message L? Well, the receiver knows that
the state is somewhere between 0 and T1,
and they know it's uniformly distributed
between 0 and T1.
So what do they think is the average
expected What do they think is the
expected state when they see message L?
Yeah?
Half of T1, right?
Cuz they're going to say, "Look, all
you've told me is the state's here. It's
uniformly distributed, so on average,
it's the midpoint of of of this
interval, which is T1 over 2."
Conversely, if the receiver gets the
message high, they're going to say,
"Okay, the state is uniformly
distributed between T1 and 1.
The average
So my updated expectation of the state
is just the midpoint of this interval,
which is the average of T1 and 1. So
this is just going to be
T1 plus 1 over 2.
Now,
we're not done yet.
We still have to worry what happens if
they get a message that's neither L nor
H, right?
Um but there's kind of a trick that we
can always use that goes back to what we
did over here.
The trick was if we see a message that
we're not supposed to see, we can just
treat it as if it were a message we were
supposed to see, and that's never going
to be a profitable deviation. So in this
case,
the receiver can say, "Look, if you send
me any message other than L or H, I'm
just going to treat that as if you had
sent me L."
So it's going to be T1 over 2.
So as if
M equals L.
And then there's never a reason for the
sender to deviate to any message other
than L or H because if they send a
message other than L or H, it's just as
if they're sending the message L, so
they might as well send the message L to
begin with. And this is a common um
kind of trick
that's used in cheap talk games.
Uh I want to emphasize I don't want to
create confusion with signaling, so I
want to say this is a trick
that doesn't work with signaling.
Let's just understand this cuz I don't
want to create confusion going back to
the signaling game. What if in the
employment context, the employer said,
"Okay, you're supposed to get this level
of education. If you don't go to school,
I'll just treat it as if you went to
school, and that shouldn't be a
profitable deviation."
That's not going to work, right? Because
they'd much rather not go to school and
form the same beliefs. So the crucial
reason this trick works is
if I can send message L
and message M and get the same decision,
I'm indifferent between those two
things.
But if the message itself were costly,
then I wouldn't necessarily be
indifferent because I'd have to take
into account not only the decision it
induced, but the cost of the message I'm
I'm sending. So this is a crucial
difference between a model with payoff
irrelevant messages and a model where
the actions I'm choosing are payoff
irrelevant. I think that's a bit of a
subtle point. So any questions on on
that difference?
Yes. Could you repeat the example of
Of the employer example, yeah. So in the
employer example, let's say we're doing
um the job market signaling, and
everyone is supposed to get Let's look
at the pooling equilibrium where
everyone goes to school for goes to
college and gets a certain wage. And the
employer says, "Okay, if you choose any
other level of education, I'm going to
treat it as if you'd gone to college for
as if you got to college and I'll pay
you the same wage as if you'd gone to
college."
Well, now
the student is going to say, "Wait a
second, if I can instead of going to
college, not go to college and get the
same wage, I'm strictly better off."
And the difference here is even though
those two actions induce the same
decision by the receiver, the actions
themselves have different costs and
therefore the student would rather not
go to college. Here,
the message L and the message M induce
the same decision, but in this case the
sender is actually indifferent between
those two things because the message
itself doesn't directly uh have a cost.
Does that clear things up?
Yeah, great. Okay.
Um
And actually that's why sort of what I
said earlier,
off-path beliefs and belief consistency
don't really make a big difference in
cheap talk games and it's really just
everything we do is basically the same
as just doing Nash equilibrium, but
that's a
that's a subtle point, that's not so
important. Okay, so here we are. Let's
see if this is going to work out. We've
specified the receiver's strategy and
now we have to check that the sender
is willing to
send these messages as they're supposed
to.
So, what's the sender supposed to do?
If they see any state
here,
they send message L.
And if they see any state here, they
send message H.
So, how can that be optimal for them?
Well, what must be true if the state is
exactly T1?
So, let's ask this.
What must be true about the sender
if the state is exactly T1? Yes, Amy?
The sender is indifferent between
sending L and sending H. They have to be
indifferent because
if the state were just a little bit to
the left, they want to send L and if
it's a little bit to the right, they
want to send M. So, the only way they
can have those preferences is if at T1,
they're exactly indifferent between
sending the message L and the message H.
So, the idea is here I'm going to be
exactly indifferent and if the state is
anywhere to the left, I want to send L
and anywhere to the right, I want to
send H. So, we're going to have what we
need is we we must have indifference.
So,
let's work this out.
Well,
that means when the state is T1,
maybe we'll write it graphically, what
we must have is
Y of L.
Maybe we'll put negatives here, it
doesn't matter.
So, if I know the state is T1,
if I send the message L,
the receiver is going to take decision Y
of L
and this is going to be my utility.
If I send the message H, the receiver is
going to take the decision Y H and this
is going to be my utility. So, in order
for me to be indifferent between these
two things, I need these two formulas to
agree.
But let's look at it graphically cuz I
think that's a bit clearer.
Well, graphically,
we have a quadratic loss function.
I'm the sender.
I know the state is T1.
What I'm going to graph is well, what
does my utility look like as a function
of the decision Y that's taken?
Well, my utility is going to look
something like this.
Here it's actually going to be
zero.
So, if the decision Y is exactly T1 +
beta, well, that's my that's the best
thing that I can get. The decision
exactly matches T1 + beta.
The difference between the decision and
T1 + beta is zero, so my loss is zero
and that's the best possible thing I
could get.
If the decision is higher than T1 +
beta, well, I'm going to experience a
loss that's quadratic and if it's lower
than T1 + beta, I'm also going to
experience a loss that's quadratic.
Now, the nice thing about the quadratic
is
it's symmetric.
So, what we need
Well, we need it the picture to look
something like this. We need the sender
to be indifferent between the decision
YL and the decision YH. And what that
means is the utility function
has to take the same value at these two
decisions.
It crosses through the same horizontal
line.
But because of symmetry,
this is only going to happen if T1 +
beta is exactly the halfway between
these two points.
If T1 + beta was closer to YL, then the
sender would rather induce the decision
YL.
And if T1 + beta was closer to YH,
they'd rather induce the decision YH.
So, we could do it algebraically, but I
think it's clearer to do it this way.
So, what we see
is T1 + beta
must be halfway between these two
things.
So, it must be
YL
plus Y of H
over two.
And now let's do just a little bit of
algebra.
We get
maybe let's multiply both sides by two
to make it a little easier. We have 2 T1
+ 2 2 2 beta
is equal to Y of L + Y of H and let's
just plug these in. So, Y of L is T1
over two.
Y of H is
T1 + 1 over two.
And that's
T1
plus 1/2.
Just put the T1 over two and T1 over two
together.
And now let's do a final
simplification.
Get T1.
T1 = 1/2 - 2 beta.
So, let's see if we can
visualize what this looks like.
If beta is zero, let's start with that
case. That's the easiest case. If beta
is zero, then T1 = 1/2.
So, that means that the sender just
says, "Is the state above average or
below average?"
But
if beta gets larger,
then T1 has to be below 1/2.
So, that this interval is smaller than
this interval.
Do you have Do you have some intuition
for why these intervals are
kind of asymmetric
in this way?
Why is it that
the interval on the right
is larger than the interval
on the left?
Yeah.
There's going to be
certain kind of
values that are right below 1/2 where
with the bias in mind,
the sender they'd be more incentivized
if the responder played high.
And so or or believed that it was high.
And so for that small range of values,
that's why T1 is biased below 1/2.
Exactly right. Yeah. So, if if it was
symmetric,
then at the midpoint, the sender would
always want to say the state is high.
So, we have to create these intervals to
be asymmetric to ensure that the sender
isn't tempted to say high and
effectively what we're doing is we're
shifting the midpoint left um in order
to counter uh that bias. So,
one one way I like to maybe think about
it is
this interval is smaller, which means
the sender is giving more precise
information about the state.
So, in order to deter the sender from
claiming the state is high, what we're
saying is well, if you say it's high,
you're not able to convey very much
information and therefore the decision
isn't going to be very precise. So, the
sender is sort of trading off the bias
of the decision against kind of the
informativeness of the decision. That's
one way of thinking about it. Um Okay,
and then one final thing. Wait a second.
T1 needs to be between zero and one.
So, we immediately see that beta has to
be pretty small in order for this to
make sense at all. Is that a question?
Yeah.
Can you explain the whole thing about
bias this about the decision and like
why does it like what benefit there is
from the precision in the lower part
versus
like having bias later?
Um I guess that's
I mean, I think the
maybe another way of
saying it is
by having the interval this interval
larger,
we're basically shifting the midpoint of
this interval farther away from me.
So, as the as the person right at the at
the threshold, I'm tempted to claim the
state is high just uh because I'm biased
and I want the state to be higher.
But as we enlarge this right interval,
well, the decision that is induced when
I say high starts getting higher and
higher because the interval is so big
and the midpoint is moving farther to
the right. And then the eventually in
the extreme case, the interval is going
to be so big um that I actually don't
want to send that the higher message and
the interval is going to be just the
right length that kind of balances those
forces. So, maybe maybe I guess the
point that I'm making is the length of
the interval determines how far the
midpoint of the interval is from the end
point of the interval. And if we made
that interval really, really big, then
the midpoint of that interval is going
to be really, really far away from its
left end point and in fact, it's going
to be too high even for the biased
sender. Um so, we have to balance these
just right.
Um
So, I interpret the midpoint being far
away from the endpoint as being saying,
"Because I'm not revealing much
information about the state, the
receiver's updated belief about the
state is very far from the true state."
But, um
maybe that's not so important.
So,
one observation here is that note that
this only works
if
2 beta is less than 1/2,
which means beta is less than 1/4.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, questions Yeah, I
uh yeah.
Yeah. Then the midpoint of the right
interval goes down cuz it's one less.
Right. So, what I'm what I'm thinking
about is the relative position of the
midpoint relative to T1. So, what
happens is if I move T1 to the left, T1
moves to the left by say an inch, the
midpoint moves to the left by only half
an inch.
So, the difference between the
endpoint and the midpoint grows.
And then at a certain point
because of like the way
the receiver's going to respond, you
would it's a little smaller difference
from the [snorts] last time. Exactly.
And that's exactly what we've done here.
We found I mean, this formula is exactly
telling us where the that point has to
be. So, you're right. I I maybe I should
have been more precise. It's true as I
move T1 left that the the high decision
gets smaller, but it doesn't get smaller
fast enough because it um you know, when
you move the the endpoint by one, you
only move the average by half.
Uh and that's exactly I mean, you can
see that here, right?
So, I guess what I'm saying is
Y of H is T1 + 1 / 2.
If we shrink T1, if we if we reduce T1
by
a little bit, then we reduce Y of H by
only half of that. But, T1 gets reduced
by the full amount.
Okay. And then so, the idea that the
left side is smaller than the right side
also just based on the idea that because
there's a beta
Exactly. Yeah. I mean, I guess very
simply all it's saying is
we're choosing the intervals so that the
midpoint of the left interval
and the midpoint of the right interval,
if we look at those two midpoints, they
average to
the cutoff point plus beta.
And that's exactly what we wrote
um
here. I mean, this is sort of the the
key the key condition. Yeah, yes.
Um
is the responder aware of the bias? And
if so, they're then incentivized to kind
of know or change their behavior given
that the senders would be lying part of
the time when they say hi. Okay, great
question. So, so first this goes to your
earlier question. They do know the bias
exactly.
Um and this is an equilibrium, so they
recognize what the sender is doing.
Uh but I I wouldn't say the sender is
lying. I mean, what the sender is doing
is the sender is telling them whether or
not the state is below T1 or above T1.
And given that message, the receiver is
behaving optimally.
Because if they get the message L,
whatever the bias of the sender, they
believe that the sender is
that the sender's message means the
state is uniform over this interval, and
therefore their optimal decision is T1 /
2. So, I mean, you're thinking exactly
about the right way. This is what the
equilibrium is capturing, um but the
receiver doesn't have any incentive to
deviate. Yeah.
Yeah, yes, other question. So, does the
the receiver know T1
Uh oh, good question. Yes.
So, T1 is is a parameter of the
equilibrium, so T1 is going to be known.
And the reason is we all or Okay, this
gets into the subtle question of what's
known, but
in equilibrium,
when the equilibrium is played, the
players have correct beliefs about what
the other players are doing. So, the
receiver believes that the sender is
following this equilibrium strategy for
this particular value of T1. So, the
receiver uh in a sense knows T1. Yeah.
So, I guess we have to be careful.
I was writing down all these formulas to
try to derive the value of T1. But, once
I've solved for T1, formally the
equilibrium is
this exact value of T1. It's not an
abstract parameter anymore. It has to be
1/2 - 2 beta, otherwise the equilibrium
wouldn't work.
Um great. So, we said this only works if
beta is less than 1/4. And indeed, you
can show that if beta is more than 1/4,
the only equilibrium is
the bad no communication equilibrium
over here.
So, let's sort of make this point over
here.
If beta
is greater than equal to 1/4,
uh
no communication
is the only equilibrium.
Now, when I say only, I mean the message
M star that we use could could be a
different message, but we're never going
to be able to convey information. And
the point here is the bias is so strong
that it's impossible to credibly convey
information. And you can think of this
in the extreme case as kind of like the
story of the worker who goes to the firm
and says, "I'm a good worker."
If the advisor has such a bias relative
to the receiver and they always want
higher decisions, the receiver just
can't listen anything they say.
And therefore, the only equilibrium is
going to be no communication.
If beta is less than 1/4,
well, we can have some coarse
communication where we reveal whether
the state is above or below this
threshold.
But, we might ask, "Well, can we convey
even more information?"
Could we have
more precise information conveyed? Do
you have any ideas how we might get
beyond this case of just above or below
a threshold? And actually convey
how might we convey even more
information uh in equilibrium?
Yeah? I had a question Yeah.
So, I was just wondering for like the
utility functions, because we say that T
is between zero and one, and then we
also have this bias, is the sender
always incentivized to um
like if T plus beta is ever greater than
one, wouldn't that mean their like
utility is always negative?
Um
Yeah, so one thing is I wouldn't Yeah,
this is a maybe a good point. Um
you might worry the way we've written
the game,
the utilities are actually always
negative.
Um Remember with utilities, we can
always add a constant to them and it
doesn't really change things. So, you
might be thinking, "Oh, they better they
rather not play the game at all. They'd
rather just not participate." Um you
could imagine the utility being 100
minus this and 100 minus this, and then
the utilities would sometimes be would
always be positive.
So, you can always, you know, the the
sender is comparing is only looking at
differences in utilities, not the
absolute levels. So, we could always
shift up the utility and it's not going
to make any difference. Yeah. So, if you
wanted, we could call this
100 minus this
and 100 minus this, and it wouldn't
change anything.
Hopefully that answers that.
Okay. So, any ideas we we have this
equilibrium where I just say the state's
either below a threshold or above a
threshold, how could we maybe convey
more precise information about the
state? Yeah?
So, the threshold idea is possible to
have like low, medium, high decisions.
I think that's the natural thing, right?
Why don't you just say it's low, medium,
high? Or maybe we could go a step
further and say split it up and say it's
either really low or a little bit low or
a little bit high or really high, right?
And it's not clear where this stops,
right? We could do a lot of this. So,
that's the going to be the idea. And
these are called
uh partitional equilibria. So, maybe
I'll erase this.
So, more generally, we're going to look
at
what are called partitional
equilibrium.
This was a special case of a partitional
equilibrium where we just had two cells.
We had two messages that said either
below or above a threshold, but more
generally,
here's our interval 01.
Why don't we do something like this? We
could say
T1,
T2, maybe it keeps going
T
K minus 1.
And we could say either the state is in
this interval or it's in this interval
or it's in this interval. This is, you
know, keeps going.
Or this interval or this interval. So,
we're basically going to our message
from the by the sender is going to
reveal which of these intervals the
state is in.
And as the number of intervals gets
really big and each of the intervals
gets really small, we're actually
converging to more and more precise
communication.
So, let's understand what's going on
here.
It's kind of convenient to call this T0
and call this TK.
So, formally what I'm going to what I'm
going to look at a partitional
equilibrium
with K cells. So, this is a K cell
partitional equilibrium
where K is greater than equal to two.
So, we have the first cell, the second
cell, the third cell, all the way up to
the K cell.
And that means we're going to have K
messages. And let's label them. Let's
just call this message one,
message two,
all the way to message K.
So, what the sender's going to do is
they're going to look at the state and
they're going to say, "Well, if the
state's between zero and T1, I'm going
to send message M1.
If it's between T1 and T2, I'm going to
send message M2. If it's between T2 and
T3, I'm going to send message M3, all
the way up to MK."
And maybe I will call write this call
this Y1. If the receiver sees message
M1, they're going to take decision Y1.
If they see M2, they're going to take Y2
and so on.
So, formally what I mean is YK is equal
to Y of M of K.
But, this is just cleaner notation.
And again, we're going to try to solve
for these parameter values
T1 up to TK minus 1. We're going to
solve for these thresholds to see if we
can make this an equilibrium.
So, what's going to have to happen?
Well, first let's use receiver
optimality.
Receiver optimality says, well, when the
receiver gets this message M1, they know
the state is somewhere between 0 and T1.
And they believe in fact the state is
uniformly distributed between 0 and T1.
So, their updated belief about the
expected state is that it's the midpoint
of this.
So, in each case, the receiver's
decision must be the midpoint of the
cell um that they're told the state is
in. So, in math language, what we would
say is YK
or YJ
Let's make sure we get this right is
going to be equal to
TJ minus 1
plus TJ
over two.
Because when they get message MJ,
they learn that the state is between TJ
minus 1 and TJ.
So, maybe we'll say this here.
Because they learn
that the state T
is between TJ minus 1
T
TJ.
Okay.
So, that gives us a formula for each of
these decisions.
This is for
J equals 1
all the way up to K.
And then, what is sender optimality
tell us?
Well, it's going to be the same idea.
At each of these split points
we want the sender to be indifferent
between sending the lower message and
the higher message. So, when the state
is T1, the sender should be indifferent
between M1 and M2.
When the state is T2, the sender should
be indifferent between M2 and M3. All
the way up when the state is TK minus 1,
they should be indifferent between MK
minus 1 and MK.
So, what that means is that TJ
plus beta
should be the midpoint
of
YJ
YJ plus 1
two. Let's make sure we got kind of the
fence post problem right.
When the state is T1, we should be
indifferent between M1 and M2, which is
YJ and YJ plus 1. So, that makes sense.
And if we did a little more
uh and this must be true for
J equals
1 to K minus 1.
Notice, we have K
conditions for the receiver
because we have K cells.
We have K minus 1 conditions for the
sender because we have K minus 1 split
points. This is the classic kind of
fence post issue that um
K minus 1 cuts gives us K pieces.
So, we could do a bit of algebra. Uh I
don't think we really need to
go through all the algebra. Let me just
uh kind of describe
what you're going to find.
So, maybe I'll just say mathematically
what this is called
is um okay, we get kind of a system of
equations.
for T1 through T
K minus 1.
Remember, we already did the case of K
equals 2.
And in the case of K equals 2, we just
solve for T1. But more generally, we
have to solve for
uh K minus 1 values.
But I want to just sort of
maybe convey the idea
intuitively. Uh
Here's how I like to think about it. We
could do the algebra, but let's just
think about it.
Let's look at adjacent cells, okay?
And let's look at what happens when the
state is here.
Okay?
Well, if these adjacent cells had the
same length
would would this Let's call this TJ.
Would the sender be indifferent between
getting this point and this point? Which
would they prefer?
Well,
these two decisions are equidistant from
TJ.
But the sender's biased, right? The
sender uh prefers the decision that's
closest to TJ plus beta. So, the sender
would always prefer the higher decision.
So, what we need
is we need TJ plus beta to be equal to
the average of these two points.
So, what we need to do is we need the
average of these two points
to shift
right
by beta.
Because if we want the sender to be
indifferent between these two points,
they shouldn't average to TJ, they
should average to TJ plus beta.
So, what we want to do is we want to
move out this interval, make this
interval longer until the average is
shifted right by beta.
Okay?
But we're only moving this point. This
point is stayed staying fixed.
So, if we want the average to go up by
beta, we have to increase this point by
two beta.
Say again? Why is the left point fixed?
Um
we're basically solving the equation
forward. We're saying, let's suppose the
left interval is like this, how big
should the next interval be? Okay,
because left intervals are given.
So, we have to increase
this point by two beta to increase the
average by beta.
But how can we increase the midpoint of
this interval by two beta? How much do
we have to increase the right end point
to get the midpoint to go up by two
beta?
Four beta, right? So, that means this
has to go up
by four beta.
Okay, we could do the algebra, but I
just kind of like to think it through.
So, what we indeed have is the general
formula is this.
And you can solve it, but I think it's
nicer to think of it
like this.
Uh let's write it this way.
So, we're comparing the lengths No, no,
no, that's wrong.
Sorry, let me rewrite this.
So, we get this formula.
Which compares the lengths of the
consecutive intervals.
So, in our
in our picture here
this is an interval length.
This is the next interval length.
And what we're saying is as we move to
the right, the next interval moving to
the right must be as long as the
interval to the left plus two beta.
Through the argument that we did over
here. Yeah. And that was just when you
originally first drew the picture, that
was saying like TJ plus 1 minus TJ was
the same length of TJ minus TJ minus 1.
And then you
And then based on the logic we
Right. So, formally in this picture, I
fixed TJ minus 1.
I fixed TJ, and I was saying how big
must TJ plus 1 be?
Um maybe it would have been easier just
to do the algebra, but I find I find
this clear. Yeah.
Um okay.
So, and actually we can check.
Let's go back to our example over here.
When T1 was equal to half minus two
beta, what were the lengths of these
intervals?
This interval
was half minus two beta.
What was the other interval?
Well, it's 1 minus that, right?
1 minus half minus two beta.
We could which equals half plus two
beta.
So, indeed that formula held in the
special case. What that midpoint was
doing is it was exactly ensuring that
the length of this interval was exactly
the length of this interval plus two
four beta.
And where did beta over four come in?
Well,
four beta has to be less than one, and
and that's where it comes comes from.
So, now we can sort of see what the
the structure of the equilibria have to
look like.
If you want to draw it more more
carefully,
as we move to the right, the intervals
are going to keep getting bigger
by a fixed amount. So, it's going to be
something like this. The first interval
has some length delta.
The next interval has some length delta
plus four beta. And the next interval
has some length delta plus eight beta.
And we can keep going.
And then we have to make sure that
everything works out at the right
interval and everything comes together.
So, what's the takeaway? Um
what we actually find
Let me just give the kind of statement
over here.
So, it can be shown, we won't go through
it,
that
there exists
a partitional equilibria
equilibrium with K cells
if and only if
beta is less than
And I think this formula can really
capture a lot of the key insights the
paper. So, let's try to understand
what's going on.
First, let's check that this is
consistent with what we did before.
So, what if we put in K equals 2?
With K equals 2,
we're back to the case we already looked
at.
And with K equals 2, the theorem says
there exists a partitional equilibrium
with two cells
if and only if beta is less than 1 over
2 * 2 * 1, which is 1/4.
So, indeed, it agrees with what we got
over here.
More generally, we get a formula like
this.
So, what does it say? Well,
as K increases,
communication becomes more precise.
As K increases, we're partitioning the
state into smaller and smaller cells,
and therefore conveying more and more
precise information about the state.
So, if we want more precise
communication, what it's telling us is
beta has to be even smaller.
So, that requires
less bias.
So, what we see
is that
the less biased that the agent is,
the more precisely it's possible for the
sender to communicate with that agent,
and the the more we can split the state
space into these very, very tiny cells
and convey more and more precise
information.
Uh and in the limiting case, when
there's no bias, we can basically
perfectly reveal the state.
Uh yes. Can you explain a little bit
more about the reasoning between precise
communication coming from less bias?
Or like the last area?
Right. So, I'm saying the last area
comes from this equation.
If we want if K grows, so we want to
have an equilibrium with a larger with
more cells,
then this inequality has to be
satisfied.
Because K is on the bottom of this
fraction, as K goes up, this fraction
gets smaller, and therefore beta has to
be smaller in order for this equilibrium
to work. Is there a reason like that's
not related to this inequality?
Oh, um
Yeah, I think the reason not related to
the inequality is that
when we provide really, really precise
information about the state, it becomes
very tempting
for the sender to misreport and claim
the state is higher than it is.
So, if we're, you know, think of the
logic of that opening case where we
fully reveal the state. If we basically
say what the state is down to, you know,
really, really strong precision, what's
the sender going to do? They're just
going to claim the state is higher.
They're going to claim it's in a higher
cell, and they're going to benefit from
that.
If they're less biased, then it's
feasible for us to split the state space
into very fine cells, and the sender
won't have an incentive to deviate.
Yeah.
So, I guess one final picture I'll show,
and I know this lecture's maybe a bit
harder, so I think I'll end maybe five
five or 10 minutes early. Um
But,
what we can look at is I think it's
helpful to look at the space of biases.
So, let's look at beta,
and let's see
what's possible in this game.
So, here we have 1/4.
And if beta is up here, then no
communication is possible.
Um
the agent's so biased that there's no
equilibrium in which any information
about the state is revealed. That's what
we already said over there.
Uh let's sort of get the numbers right.
If we have three,
we have six. It's already 1/12.
I think we'll
get down to something like 1/12.
So, here,
there is
a two-cell
equilibrium
only.
If the bias is between 1/12 and 1/4,
then the only way the only equilibrium
it can be shown is the kind of
equilibrium we described where you
either say the state is above or below a
threshold.
And we're going to keep going down and
down and down,
and then here, in this case, we're going
to have a two-cell
and a three-cell equilibrium.
So, for a lower level of bias, there
will be a two-cell equilibria where the
sender just says the state's above or
below a threshold.
There will also be a three-cell
equilibria
where the sender says the state is
either low, medium, or high, but that's
it. There's nothing else.
And then if we get down to here, there's
going to be a two-cell, a three-cell,
and a four-cell.
And as we keep going,
as beta keeps getting smaller and
smaller, the set of equilibria grows. We
have more and more equilibria, and we
have equilibria with more and more cells
that provide more and more precise
communication. And the limit as beta
gets really close to zero, we have very
informative equilibria.
And maybe one final observation I'll
make
is
let's suppose beta is small enough so
that there's a range of equilibria.
There's a one-cell, there's a two-
there's a two-cell, there's a
three-cell, there's a four-cell. The
question is, which equilibrium
is best for the players?
Any intuition for this? Let's say we're
in a case Let's say beta is here. So, we
have both a two-cell and a three-cell.
What do you think is better? Yeah.
Or do you have a question? Yeah. I was
going to say I think for the receiver
it's probably better to have more cells
rather than getting closer. Exactly
right. So, it's it's definitely better
for the receiver because if there's more
cells in the equilibrium, the receiver
is just getting more information about
the state, and therefore they're able to
take make more accurate decisions.
Uh it may be less obvious, but it's
actually better for the sender as well.
So, it turns out uh
the highest K
is best
for both the sender and the receiver.
So, for any value of beta, depending on
the value of beta, there's going to be a
range of equilibria. There's going to be
some uninformative equilibria. In fact,
there's always the babbling equilibrium
where you don't reveal anything. There
might be a two-cell where I just say
it's high or low. There might be a
three-cell where I say it's high,
medium, or low. A four-cell. The high
the biggest number of cells that that
can exist as an equilibrium, that's
going to be the most informative
equilibrium, and it turns out that's
going to be the equilibrium that's best
for the sender and and also for the
receiver.
Um
So, maybe that's some sort of prediction
about uh what we might expect to see.
Yes, Amy. So, it makes sense that it's
best for the receiver just because when
you get closer, your receiver gets more
info. Yeah. And how does the sender
benefit? Is it also the same reason? Um
Yeah, it's actually a property of the
quadratic um
loss. So, I think the intuition is that
because the receiver is always matching
the decision with their expectation of
the state,
the sender can never
shift the decision. So, it We're getting
into kind of a technical point, but it
turns out the expected decision is
always going to be equal to the expected
state.
And as the cells get smaller,
the benefit is that the state is
conveyed more precisely, and therefore
that higher decisions are taken in
higher states and lower decisions in
lower states, and that's going to be
better for the sender. Uh but the basic
intuition is that the
the
um
I guess Okay, the formal answer would be
it's like a bias-variance decomposition.
Um you can express the expected loss as
like the bias of the error and the and
the variance of the error, and the bias
is fixed, and the variance you're going
to make smaller. But, I'm happy to talk
more offline if if you want to go into
that more depth.
Um Okay, so I think that was a a bit of
a harder lecture. Just let me stop
there. I know we're near the end of the
semester. I'll give people an early
stop, and I will see everyone on Tuesday
for the last lecture.